mmm I never really caught on to the
kombucha fad but sometimes like I'll
walk through the aisles and then
sometimes I'm tempted and then I'll try
it but I liked kombucha before I like
discovered how it was made
cuz it's like mushrooms right like it's
fermented mushrooms or it's some it's
some weird process
it tasted like very vinegary but I know
it's it's healthy like I would probably
drink it just for the health benefits
but I'm still still enjoying my tea
let's play e4 I've been getting a few
requests to do like climbing the rating
ladder series so this will be kind of on
the lower end of the ladder
playing against a scandi attacking the
Queen this guy probably just binges John
Bartholomew if he plays a scandi but
maybe not because John Bartholomew is
not recommending Queen e5 as far as I
know let's just do this
the problem with Queen e5 I just can
attack it with tempo so blacks losing a
lot of time that's usually why black
plays Queen a5 or Queen d8 so the Queen
can't easily be attacked
depending where the Queen goes I might
continue to harass it Queen d6 I could
consider considering Knight b5 Queen a5
I can play this thing is that black will
play c6 and just retreats if I play
Bishop c4 we can actually transpose to a
mainline which I don't necessarily want
so let's play Knight f3 just accelerate
development usually lock should develop
a bishop before playing e6 I think in
this position I'll play a tricky move
Knight e5 GABA then Bishop b4 I'll still
go for it this is tricky because I have
a threat of Knight c4 and then the Queen
is like almost trapped so there's a
couple moves for luck there's this kind
of safe move there's also a bishop
before probably the most testing move I
could be fancy in just castle and sac
upon trying to calculate like castle a
nice a cap on the rooks attacked but the
Queen's the target I played Bishop g5
yeah I'm gonna just rely on some
intuition and I just want a position
where there is like tactical
possibilities like the queen is still
very much a target black is
underdeveloped but I am down the pawn so
I have to prove something fantasizing
about rook lifting or just taking on f6
and damaging the structure
some idea of Bishop d2 but Bishop d2
queen takes d4 hmm
97 now I'm fantasizing about like takes
takes Knight goes somewhere and now I
made on d8 so I think I'll start with
rook to be one just carrying through
with other plan of lifting oh is it
gonna happen oh but the Queen can take
on e5
so do I throw in this move
maybe I throw in that move don't see
anything wrong with it I didn't really
intend to sacrifice two pawns maybe I'm
getting a little bit carried away but I
think okay I mean I'm gonna take back
the night and the Queen won't be able to
capture on e5 if the Queen moves to a5 I
could throw in like another kind of
wishing Zoo I'm still trying to like get
this meat on d8 so still if takes takes
so probably rook d5 just making sure
there's nothing there is something for a
block actually like black could be very
tricky with Knight f3 check kind of a
desperado he's gonna lose the night
anyway I can't take with the bishop
because I'm queen takes rook so I could
take with the pawn or I could play King
h1 even
strange position things get stranger
well I could also take on a two and then
I take here I'm probably pretty happy
yeah so much happiness because now okay
stuff is happening if ninety five I have
c4 explosive if ninety seven not
entirely sure what I have but I probably
have something I've 94 I have made in
one so it happened didn't I call it like
moves ago I have to go back and watch
the replay but I'm pretty sure I
predicted the future like when I played
Bishop g5 like my fantasy came true
alright so that's probably another like
tidbit of YouTube content so a lot of my
youtube videos are just like full
streams where it's hard to like
categorize so I'll just have to come up
with like names based on these games so
for the YouTube audience thanks for
watching again smash the subscribe
button and I'll see you in the future